um basically what I'm saying is that yes
you know not all of us were taught to be
wives yeah right and maybe that's
because our mothers saw what happened to
wives well I've not all of us would talk
to sucker Whoa stop oh wait wait wait no
no no no no okay okay
um did you hear what I said first yeah
so so you say that again yes so just
just the one part just the part about
you they were not taught why yeah let me
not get him okay because you're right
what I'm saying is that don't worry girl
woman that raised certain woman in this
world they never taught their children
or their daughters obviously wives
because they had experienced what
happens to wives and they were like I'm
not gonna be a wife because that means I
have to stand up with a guy and that's
due to relationships but what what
outcomes are better
but this is but this is this is the
thing like single single single child
single childless women are not happy by
and large they're not over over there
only happiness though I mean what okay
what do you want your life to look like
okay no no listen listen two seconds
just listen what do you want your life
to look like at 60 65. what do you want
Christmas to look like your fan your
family I just wanted to look whole okay
okay not listen listen Okay what do you
do you want to spend it alone at 65.
your parents are probably passed away
then on 70 65. for myself definitely not
okay for me personally right so what are
you arguing about here I'm arguing that
community and having family and being a
single woman doesn't come with a lonely
life
the stats disagree no women the women
that don't have children are on
antidepressants
disagree that's okay that's okay because
so then what are you what you are
probably on
antidepressants and they on they drink
tap water and they do certain things
that's not fun no no and then you know
they're they're just okay are are there
are those are the single childless women
that you know typically happy are they
happy they're in that position typically
like majority of the time okay they're
they're all happy yes and if they and if
they had to pick they would rather be by
themselves than with a man they respect
love and admire yeah they would prefer
that no no pick one what would they
prefer typically pick but how could I
pick one no that's not an option if
what's I'm giving you two options they'd
rather be alone or with a man that they
love respect and admire which one would
they pick the rough wait
according to the stats you're right and
I'm wrong but according to my world and
my people my community
we're good but yeah we're good on this
but it's true what you said not a lot of
women have taught their um girls because
they haven't come from that background
no but no no no no no
through it because
why is that your answer it's a painful
reality
because when I talk when I'm saying the
woman that we're not raised to be wives
it's because their mothers had
experienced something else
and that might be the majority that's
why there's so many women who aren't
wives who have to go to wife's school I
think she means that it's a knock-on
effect to say someone's great grandma
went through some sort of trauma yes you
mentioned him earlier they're gonna pass
it down to their door yeah they ain't
gonna teach them how to then it goes
down to it it's a knock on effect what
they're saying it's generational
but but the difference is people used to
go through trauma together
yeah like I mean I know a couple I know
a couple that had they lost a child and
that that's real trauma they lost a
child and they they stuck it out and
they figured out a way to make it work
and they ended up having more kids but
that ruins most relationships that's
real trauma nowadays women's trauma is
just not being happy having to listen to
their husband do you know
do you feel like in this generation now
a lot of women are so quick to throw in
the towel is that what you feel like yes
yeah and I agree with you I
agreement
so I'm saying I'm doing a documentary on
the court system in the UK and I I can
tell you firsthand men are not the first
to throw in the not
multiple times
so it might be for the kids but that the
men are more selfless than the women
because they care about the kids they'll
stick it out for the kids
I just interviewed a guy
I am talking about marriage she was
married he he has three daughters and he
was married to a narcissist and he said
that he would have stuck it out
but she wouldn't wow so then one day he
gets a call he can't go home she got a
restraining order against him she
accused him of abuse and now he can't
see his children three daughters and he
hasn't even gotten to fight in court in
the last year
and all he wants is just to see his kids
to bring his family together we hear
this and this woman had had no real
reason and I'm telling you I'm doing a
documentary on this it's like the same
story over and over again because here
the courts think about if you're if
you're in a contract right and person a
gets everything by leaving they get the
house they get the kids they get
everything in person B
um they lose everything person B is
always trying to to please person a
because they have more to lose so it
changes the way we interact in
relationships in my opinion where that's
why we always have like women wearing
the pants especially in the west because
the men are always trying to appease the
women because they lose everything if
they leave so yeah I do I do think women
today throw on the towel and partially
it's because they're paid to April I've
had clients cry to me I've had like in
law offices the partners I've had them
cry to me over the years because of the
divorce they're going through and not
being able to see their kids yes and
it's and it's like and we know
statistically it's 80 of women that
leave their relationships I've had grown
ass men cry to me about it like I've had
that relation where they're like dude
and they just ball yeah I know many men
I know men I've met many men who are
actually depressed and that's how they
go into depression because they've lost
their kids and the mother is usually
being spot for just not letting them see
their kid not giving them the right can
I say something though
um I don't want to justify the thing
that
um women sometimes they can be evil
take their kids and use them against
their husbands but you have to check how
many marriage are made where the woman
she does everything she goes to work she
take care of kids she does everything
and the man just goes to work and goes
home and she'll sit down like you don't
really know the reason why people
divorce and like I believe there's so
many marriages nowadays why did she have
a kid with a guy that just sits at the
couch all day I mean why did she pick
him no because the most of the men they
say that like men in business or
whatever Men by and large make more than
women sorry Men by and large make more
than women yeah I know but because they
make more than women they they feel that
they are able to like just go home and
chill or watch the TV or go with their
friends to drink a beer while the woman
actually goes to work she looks after
the kids she take care of the house she
pays the bill she does she does
everything
okay this is literally we talked about
this today with Creole so this is really
interesting and again this is going to
be super offensive so let's go viral uh
hmm
first thing okay
like
Messi the football soccer football
player his wife isn't leaving him
because he doesn't do the dishes
when the wife's a guy left him because
he didn't do the chores it's like that
LeBron is LeBron's wife leaving him
because he doesn't do the dishes that's
a [__] reason that's not true let me
tell you what is true the answer is he's
not if if a wife is like I'm leaving
because my husband doesn't do chores
it's because he's not making enough
money that's the reason now and the
stats I'll make it very simple and you
guys are gonna I hate this I told it's
going to be here it's true so so I that
makes sense listen up I come I come home
if you do the logic I come home and I'm
like I just work like a 14-hour day I'm
super tired you know I whatever pull my
portion next to my wife's G wagon that I
got her she's very cool everything's
great and I'm freaking tired and I can
see my wife which we got four kids she's
working really hard around the house and
I'm like honey listen um let me just get
a mate to come in and clean the house
and my wife's like no no I I want to do
this myself and I'm like look I know I'm
not gonna do it I'll tell you I'm not
gonna I just worked 14 hours I'm gonna
touch a dish in my life and I told her
if I'm single I have a full-time living
maid and my like I'll literally get a
nanny for myself if I'm single and she
will just do everything so finally I
convinced my wife
to get a lady to come in and help around
the house so in comes like this hot 23
year old Ukrainian girl that's now
living in Estonia as a refugee and she's
in there wiping the everything I see my
wife do the side she never showed up
again
she's scaring people I did what I'm
saying is gentlemen this is going to be
offensive listen up if you ever if you
don't want to do dishes and you are
successful enough to hire a mate hire a
hot maid and I promise your wife will do
the damn dishes
I want to give you guys a stat wait no
wait
um surprisingly studies showed that the
divorce rate among couples who share
chores equally was 50 higher than among
those where the wife does the majority
of the work it's a financial yeah I know
but I'm not saying I'm not saying
because the men like because the men
doesn't do because obviously the woman
for nature like even like in all the
religion right the woman is the one that
she looks after the kids after the house
and everything but like at the same time
if a man can make like that type of
amount of money that he can come home
until then why her wife's shoes should
go to work and be like oh I have to take
care of everything like if she if her
wife can decide to be at home and be
like oh don't want to have like a really
do you think a successful men want their
wives to work does your wife work I no I
I told her when I married her I said I
want my mom work my mom I'll earned my
dad so my parents got divorced and it
was and I saw it as a kid I was in the
dumb kid I'm like I know why it's
happening because my mom started out
earning my dad I told my wife I'm like
look when we get married I want my wife
to be a stay-home mom I was very open
about it it's because I want my kids
have an experience I didn't have and I
want to work my ass off to provide my
kids that experience okay as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible